all right jessica
jessica where'd you rob where you from
originally
from kingsport tennessee kingsport i've
been there uh tell me about your family
growing up you had uh
both your parents
yes um
well some of my earliest memories are
being um
being hungry and
beating on my bathroom door for hours
trying to get my mom and dad to come out
while he was in there shooting up
cocaine um
my dad when i was 12
he traded my virginity for two blue
valiums
um
then he decided that he liked me my dad
did and he raped me and he told me he
was in love with me he wanted me he
loved me more than he did my mom and he
wanted me not to call him dad anymore
um he wanted to be with me he wanted to
leave my mom and be with me and um
he had been doing that for a while
i finally told my mom about it and um
she
didn't believe me at first and then she
kind of seen some things and she she
knew that it was true but she blamed me
for it she told me that um if i hadn't
wanted it to happen it wouldn't have
that it was my fault
you had a sexual relationship with your
dad yes for how long
um like two years
um how old were you
how about now how old were you in there
13
yeah um
and
see um so that went on and um
when i was 14 i was so um just
you know i was so alone i didn't have my
mom to help me i didn't have my my dad
was like he was and my mom was like from
that moment when she found out my dad
was doing that she didn't look at me as
her daughter anymore she looked at me as
a woman her husband was cheating on her
with you know
and um so
at 14 my mom dad started giving me shots
of morphine
um
i got addicted to it um that was my
first love before any man or woman there
was morphine
and that i had a long affair with that
um
i would be i ended up getting down to
like 102 pounds and i was real sick and
i um
ended up dealing with this guy and my
dad didn't want me to be with him so i
would have to get a weapon you know i'd
get whipped every beat whatever every
day to just be able to go be with him um
but i i loved him and i'd do it you know
i did anything to try to be with him so
i took it every day
and i and then i just go be with him and
on my 16th birthday i found out i was
pregnant
um
i did not um
[Music]
i told my mom and dad and my dad told me
if i didn't have an abortion that i
couldn't live there anymore
so i said no
and i left and i was living
with a friend and my boyfriend and um
ended up having a miscarriage and i kind
of it just it hit me real hard i look
back on everything you know i was 16 i
already had a miscarriage but i had all
that stuff going on with my dad and then
um
addicted to morphine shooting up you
know junkie already
and um
i just i was thinking about my sisters i
have two little sisters and um
my middle sister she was 10 and they
already started letting her like smoke
weed and drink and stuff like that so
i didn't i did i just seen her going
through the same things i did and i
didn't want that to happen
i don't know um my my dad
i came back home after i had the
miscarriage and um
you know i was i was like i said i was
swimming out my dad didn't want me to go
get him some pills and i couldn't find
any
he smacked me in the face i had this big
handprint on my face and
um one of the neighbors seen it called
the wall they came up there
and um
i begged them to put me in lock up
foster care anywhere and they would and
they put me next door at my grandparents
house which is my dad's parents and um
i ended up running away that night i
climbed out the window and left and um
i was going for a couple months
and then um the police found me
and um they um were taking me back but
one of the police officers
lived on the same street as me that was
the one that was taking me she was she
lived on the same street as me and she
knew about my mom and dad she knew you
know they did drugs she knew about me
being on drugs i mean everybody knew it
it was just
so she asked me if i wanted to go back
there because of all of it and i told
her no
they went and they searched my mom and
dad's house
and they found needles with morphine and
you know shots already made and all this
stuff my mom and dad tried to tell them
that they were mine that i planted them
there i had been there in months you
know i'd run away so
i knew they were lying they checked they
gave them drug tests they checked their
arms and seen that you know the track
marks and the all that stuff so they
took me and my sisters away that day
and um
i was in foster care till i turned
18.
um
when i turned 18 i left my sisters were
still there they were in good you know
health my parents didn't
stop doing drugs they quit doing
morphine and started smoking crack
and um so they didn't get my sister's
back i turned 18 first and so i aged out
of foster care that my sisters got
adopted
um
so when i was 18 i got a job at a hotel
um
i worked the front desk the graveyard
shift and um
they let me keep a room there because i
didn't have anywhere to go i didn't want
to go to my mom and dad's because of you
know the drugs and stuff i was trying to
stay up with drugs
and um
one of my friends she was she was
actually my best friend then um she came
over one day and um
she was like
she had these five guys with her she had
been trying to go to a club but the club
was closed it's called two two nine they
don't have it no more but the club was
closed and she picked up these guys on
the corner and um
they were gonna smoke some weed with her
and they'd drink and stuff and she asked
me if she could use my room while i was
working i was like yeah that's fine you
know just be going before i get back
because i'll be wanting to go to sleep
well
i was in the bathroom when they came in
they came in and sit down on the beds
and stuff or whatever and i was putting
my makeup when one of them came in there
and jerked me out of the bathroom
they ripped off my clothes
um they already had her on the bed they
held his face down on the bed and raped
us took turns raping us all five of them
um
they videotaped it
i didn't get to see them
because they had me face down you know i
didn't really get to see them i wasn't
out there when they came in or nothing
and when that the only one i seen was
the one that jerked me out of the
bathroom
i remember his face now but i've never
seen him again
but um
they videotaped it and then after they
were done
it seems like it went on forever
but after they were done um
they threw some crack on the floor and
left
like
it's very degrading
um
it really [ __ ] me up real bad i
started hating
black people because of it and i i'd
never been like that before you know i'd
been the opposite because my my parents
you know they were racist my whole
family was and i mean it's just where
i'm from that's
how it is
and um
anyway um
so i ended up getting into some trouble
a little later on and i um
went to jail
i ended up getting involved in the aryan
gang um
one of them um
how'd that happen
how did that happen well um this girl i
ended up dating um her brother was a
lieutenant
and
um
the lieutenant in the
i don't think
i don't think i should always say that
um well i don't care actually very
nation and um
they um
anyway i got
my patches whatever i
did what i was asked to do
um
so i got into that real heavy for a
while um
then later on found out that the dude
that you know put the patches on me and
everything was not who he said he was he
was not ranked like he said he was
he wasn't a lieutenant
like i was
told being raped by
african-americans kind of help you
decide that this was okay
um
yes it did it
i didn't look at it as just
those five guys did that to me i looked
at it as it was a whole the whole you
know
um i was wrong for that and i know that
um but
i mean i was young and i was stupid
and i didn't
i mean i didn't
really think about it i had never really
been around
a lot of a lot of black people i've had
you know um it was like two in my high
school that was it you know
there was no mexicans nothing like that
that was just
a lot of people
um
i um
had been on drugs real heavy the whole
time
um
i went from morphine to
i'd quit there when i was in foster care
and when i first got out of foster care
i wasn't i smoked weed a little bit
every once in a while
don't drink it all because my dad was
drunk whenever he did the stuff he did
to me and um that's all i could smell
and and whenever i smell alcohol even
now it kind of brings back all that and
i don't even so i don't mess with it at
all
um
but
the group the aryan group that you were
with they they were involved in drugs as
well yeah
yes they um
controlled most of the math that went
through that part of the
area um
pretty much all of it i guess from what
i know um
but um
so i got on that robot i mean it was
free to me i know that people
they see you're part of that and
they automatically like defer to you
they
it's a lot different
but i found out like i said that the
dude wasn't really what he said he was
he shouldn't have put the patches on me
so none of it was
legit when you say patches what do you
mean patches um the tattoos i have or
the tattoos yeah yeah
my number all that stuff um none of it
was real uh
it was all he had lied to me the whole
time just to
because he was trying to [ __ ] me
so
now i have these tattoos
and
these people are mad that i have them
and i'm not really
done i mean i did what he had asked me
to do everything
um
but it didn't matter because he was not
ranked high enough to be able to make
that decision
so um
they ended up
upset with me and they they've
constantly tormented me actually um
had people come and say they were giving
me tests
and this wasn't even the
alienation this was a different airing
game they came and they wanted to give
me tests and um
i went and did it you know i did what
they asked me to do just because
i wanted to belong to something i guess
i wanted a family i never really had one
my parents were always so [ __ ] up and
just
they weren't there they tried to be
friends when they were there they
wouldn't try to be parents
um
so
you know i wanted the family i thought
that that would be my family and then
they all just kind of turned on me
um
so i went way out there i started dating
this black guy i put um pictures of me
and him on facebook kissing and in bed
together and everything so that was real
bad that was like a smack in the face to
them you know what i mean
um
then i got
i was married
i ended up getting married to well i'm
still married um but for 11 years i was
with my husband i was a housewife then
you know i didn't really do much nothing
i didn't i was started i got off
everything started going to a subutex
clinic um you married your
the black boyfriend no he was what oh so
after that
yeah um no here's why um
i mean as like i said i was living for
11 years i had two kids i have a 15 year
old daughter right now and a 13 year old
son i have two step kids that are
20 and 24.
um
i was just a mom and a wife and i
did the whole housewife thing you know
but i stayed [ __ ] up the on subby tech
and klonopins the whole time um
i don't even remember a lot of it
because of it
i don't remember ever being happy in my
life like truly happy you know
everybody searches for i don't ever
remember having that
um maybe on the day my kids were born i
mean i was real happy then but
i was sad too because it felt like
i was suffocating
it felt like i was everything i ever
wanted was being took away from me at
that time because
i mean what you're supposed to do once
you have kids you can't go and do the
things you want to do really you have to
take care of them
um
i didn't have anybody to help me you
know it's just me my husband left me all
the time he cheated on me all the time
he beat me he knocked my teeth out he um
a gun in my head and told me it's going
to kill me it was a 357. um
he pulled the trigger even um
but
it ended up um my stepson had been
messing with it that day and he had
cleaned it and unloaded it and stuff and
um so there was no bullets in it thank
god but i thought i was i thought i was
dead right then
you know
um
but anyway i ended up
stealing a credit card at that time i
got my first felonies i was in jail
again
someone reverted back to the same ways
you know with the same people it's
always the same people in there um
and um
got you know back in with it and people
and
um i did three years
that time
um
then i um
went back to my husband stayed there for
a while
he was just it was just real bad we we
had ended up hating each other you know
um
at first he was the one that back a long
time ago that called the law whenever my
dad hit me he was that neighbor that did
that
and he's 10 years older than i am um
i babysit my step kids you know he
should babysit him
um
i think i had like a savior complex i
feel like he saved me from my parents at
that time and i feel like i owed him
so i stayed with him even though he did
all that stuff because i mean loyalty is
something that's very important to me um
[Music]
so
he
he kept on doing that stuff
i ended up we ended up losing our house
causing both of our drug problems we
lost our house that we've had for six or
seven years um
i ended up living in a hotel for two
years the hotel was just a big drug area
i got a mess then um
[Music]
when i got a mess he started looking
down on me real bad and um
i ended up going to jail for a
criminal trespassing charge and but i
had all my medications on me and i had
hid them
um i stuffed them you know how females
do whatever and um
i was so messed up when i go out into
this jail cell
it was before they sent me to the county
it was the city jail and it's small it's
just like two little cells and and they
don't keep you there they just hold you
there for long enough to for the county
to come get you
and um
so then i took all those pills out and i
was doing some on the i snorted an
appeal on the
bench and
the lady came around this the jailer
came around the side of the
corner and i
tried to hide those pills real fast and
they just dropped everywhere pills
everywhere
so
they seen them and they charged me with
introduction of contraband into a panel
facility
um
i got four and a half years for that
um
my husband left me
um my kids got took away
um
he has them he has them now
he doesn't let me talk to them but i
still do i mean i talk to my messenger
but i'm not supposed to
um when i talk to my daughter mostly my
son doesn't get on there but sometimes
he's in a room and i'll talk to him too
um
i think he knows that i talk to them but
she has to try to hide it you know still
but i think he still knows because he
said stuff to me
about it when i've talked to him
um
[Music]
he um at that hotel i ended up getting
real messed up and i um
i never cheated on him even though he
cheated on me so many times i met this
dude
and uh he's he's a black guy and um
i don't know for some reason i guess
because of the way i was raised the
my parents it's like a forbidden thing
you know you want what you're not
supposed to have
and um so i've always been very
attracted
um
[Music]
but i ended up sleeping with that black
guy on the balcony of the hotel
i had all my clothes off the owner
um seeing me because he hadn't you know
i don't want to go into all that but
anyway um the owner seen me out there
and he seen my you know my tattoos and
stuff so he knew for sure it was me and
he went to my husband
about it
well my husband made a big deal about it
because it was a black guy and told me
that he couldn't even stand to be with
me anymore and all this bunch of stuff
because he was black and um also so but
now my husband his girlfriend has mixed
kids and um
all kinds of stuff it's crazy
the way he acted and i don't know i just
my friend told me that he you know it's
probably just an excuse to leave me i
mean he used that probably but he could
have left me anyway he did it all the
time i mean i was the one that was
always there
no matter what and he was leaving all
the time
but
um
so he left me while i was in jail and
i did the four and a half years i ended
up flattening it i had it i didn't get
i made parole but then it got messed up
and i didn't get to go out on parole and
um
they gave me a community corrections
program and i ended up running from it
so they put me back in there again and i
just ended up doing it all
so i did um
about three years flat
and um all together i was out three
months of the three years
or two and a half months two and a half
months so three years and um
i got out of jail march 30th of this
year
um
oh this guy
this guy um
was very
controlling narcissistic at first the
first day i was with him
we stayed going all day and all night i
ended up falling asleep i'd been up for
days just doing meth a lot um
i had been i was a booster i you know
went to stores and
got what people wanted they gave me a
list i went to stores i got it that's
how my money
and um
or
other than that i would get people you
know drugs i'd get what they wanted for
them and then you know make something
off of it and take that something and
turn it into something else and just you
know keep on going until i had something
and um
that's how i was making money i was
paying for a hotel room every day for me
my mom to stay in us buying our
cigarettes our food our drugs our
everything
and i was that dude and everything just
fell apart and one day
i came back to the hotel we were kicked
out of it
banned from it because my mom was
smoking in there and she wasn't supposed
to be
um
so i lost where i was living
um
he
me my mom doesn't have a good
relationship
because of what happened with my dad we
still don't even today
i love her but i hate her that's just
how it is i resent her completely for
leaving me all alone when i needed her
the most
um
she has
done some real [ __ ] up things to me um
that dude
the way my mom talks to me is real bad
and that dude got real mad about it and
um his name is cory he got real mad
about it and he told um
he went off with my mom i mean he cussed
her out tossed it she couldn't talk to
me like that if she was going to talk to
me like that she didn't need to leave if
she needed to leave and didn't need to
come back
and um she him and her started arguing
and he told her to get the [ __ ] out and
not come back
so he that was the first day he got rid
of my mom
that was and she was a like
even though i mean her have a bad
relationship we're close still at the
same time
she knows pretty much everything i do
you know um
she did she don't know but um
so
he got rid of her and then it was like a
systematically
every person i talked to
something happened because of him to
where i they didn't talk to me no more
my uncles my aunts my
cousins i have no one that will talk to
me or my grandfather the last time i
talked to my grandfather he told me that
there was no room for me in his house
anymore that i couldn't even come in and
visit i could sit on the porch
like i was uh
i don't know
but
um so
yeah i was all alone again and he was
the only person i had and that's how he
wanted it to be he made it be like that
you know he went stole stuff from my
uncle and left something there that was
my uncle had seen me have so my uncle
automatically thought it was me even
though i was nowhere around where he
lived
you know that time
but my uncle believes it was me
um
he did that on purpose i know he did
with everything in me i know he did he
will deny
but i know he did um
he led he had me believing
because i'm i'm paranoid i have i have
schizophrenia
and ptsd
depression anxiety disorder i have all
that stuff um i take all kinds of
medicine
but um
so i like i said i'm real paranoid i was
doing math too i was shooting meth in
real bad
and um
he had me believing that people were
chasing me after me the aryan gangs and
another gang um too
um
had me believing that all them were
chasing me and people were he had people
that were his friends that would follow
me around whenever i would leave him
we'd get in a fight i believe he did on
purpose he just did like
have be away from me for a couple days i
guess to do whatever he was doing i
don't know what all he's doing
but um
it was crazy if these people chase me i
would run for days at a time and not
stop my feet would have blisters and be
bleeding and i'd be
i'd be so tired and thirsty i'd go into
restaurants and beg them for cups of ice
water i would um because i had no money
i mean he left me with nothing
he had he would take all my clothes he
would take everything
um
and i mean there was actually really
people there that chased me cars that
followed me around i would see him as i
was going where he'd be
passing me in a car that i'd never seen
any man before but it was him
he had me believing he had a twin he had
me believing that um i mean just all
kinds of stuff he like brainwashed me to
a point where
it was to the point where i was so
scared of everything i couldn't boost no
more so i didn't have a way to make any
money i had no idea to get a job i had
you know nothing like that all my stuff
had been stolen from me everything owned
um
i lived in fear i would not hardly go
out i wouldn't go to no one's house i
wouldn't talk to no one i couldn't look
nobody in the eye
um i looked down all the time i felt
like i was worthless like i was i hadn't
he took my pride and my confidence for
me
and i let him and i hate myself for that
because i let him do it
so it seems like since you've been doing
crystal meth your life has gone a little
haywire crazy i've lost everything
because of it everything my husband my
kids my um your paranoia gets out of
control yes so that's why i've had to
quit doing it i can't
i can do it i can smoke it it doesn't do
that to me but any other way i do it
um
what are you using today
nothing just have to take my medicine
that's it
um so you left yes i love to see you
left tennessee to come to l.a yes i
left straight from tennessee um how long
are you supposed to be how old am i 34.
no no how long ago oh about
two weeks ago is when i left i got stuck
in mississippi for a week
so what are you hoping for by coming to
l.a in schedule
it's a new start of something different
i just want to live i've spent so much
time existing i want to live
that's my thing
i
went life without being happy
i
had what i wanted you know i had the
family had the kids i was so unhappy and
i thought that's what i wanted so much
and
i lost it
i was real sad was real upset but at the
same time it was like a
a big weight was lifted off my shoulders
and i i know that sounds horrible to say
because i love my kids more than
anything i'd do anything for them
so i've obviously quit drugs i haven't
been able to do that yet but i'm about
there
um
i just
i'm on a different life
i've
been a drug addict my whole life that's
all i've ever known it's my best friend
you know it's always been there never
left you know never left
are drugs pretty common where you're
from kingsborough oh yes
everybody i know there's unmath besides
my grandparents my grandfather and my
aunts and uncles well some of them are
but a few of them aren't but other than
that everybody i know is
my my daughter even got on drugs and was
in a mental institution she kept trying
to kill herself
she was 13 12 and 13. she told me
finally that my stepson had been raping
her that for years
i haven't even been able to touch her to
hold her to to be there for her
she's smoking crystal meth
she was doing all kinds of different
stuff my mom is the one that started
giving it to her
um at what age
at 12 i guess 11 or 12. i was in jail
i got a letter from her she was in a
mental hospital i got a letter
and um
she said hey mom i just want to let you
know what's been going on
i got i got on drugs
um
i tried to kill myself several times
they put me in a mental institution she
pierced all of her face her all over her
face was pierced in the mental
institution so they sent her to a
different one in knoxville
um
you can see and um
she was there for like three or four
months and um
she kept
going out with this black guy i guess he
raped her um
she got caught with him and he was like
20 something and she was just 13.
she didn't tell them nothing about him
doing that to her or anything
but she got trouble for being having
drugs and him being there and all that
stuff and
i guess he got trouble too i'm not sure
i've not been there nobody's told me
nothing my husband has not said one word
about it i only know what my daughter's
taught me
and um
i mean i know he said a few things about
her being in the mental place but he
hasn't said anything about you know the
drugs or nothing except for my mom he
told me my mom was giving her pills but
my mom lived with him while i was in
jail for a little while and helped him
take care of the kids
i guess take care of them she gave them
pills to make them
whatever
um i hate that i hate her for that i'll
never forgive her for that
never
um
but i have it like i said i haven't been
able to
comfort her to be there in any way at
all and i feel like such a piece of [ __ ]
for that
um
i wanted nothing more than to be a good
mom but i just can't i just
i'm not a bad mom no
i just can't
i have so much of my past that i can't i
haven't been able to let go of
that um
[Music]
it's chased me it seems like it won't
leave me alone
um
and
because of that i want to stay numb
[Music]
and that's do i have the drugs and then
because of the drugs i can't be there
for them like i want to be my daughter
told me she will not have nothing to do
with me
until
i quit doing drugs
she said i take my medicine smoke weed
she smokes weed still she quit doing
everything but smoking weed
um
she smoked cigarettes and stuff but um
and in tennessee it's not legal you know
it's not legal smoke weight or nothing
so it's a big deal for her
she um
her birthday her on her 15th birthday
was in october
my husband was gonna let me come to her
party
she didn't want me there
that was the worst feeling i've ever
felt in my life
she said until i stopped doing drugs
that she didn't want me around and i'm
honest with her about everything i tell
her what i'm doing
she'll ask me if i'm high she'll ask me
what i've been doing and i tell her
because i just i've always been honest
with her about stuff
she's mature for her age very mature
um
i don't know if i should be that honest
with her or not but that's how i am
um
do you think the
the core of all your problems
all your
long lists of problems is
the environment you grow up in or the
family that you grew up in or yes i i
sincerely believe bad decisions on your
partner yes i mean i don't blame my
parents i made the decisions i made i
made the decisions to let them the only
thing i blame them for is him my dad
breaking me and doing what he did to my
head my mom doing what she did
but the drugs and stuff i made that
decision ultimately i told them yeah do
it you know
they shouldn't have did it no they were
supposed to be my parents
but i didn't want to feel nothing
i had been i had
when i started shooting morphine i'd
already been on nerve pills real bad
um
my mom would get her clown up and she
would get 90 kilometers and she comes
straight in hand me 10 hand my dad's 10
and then her 10 and we all took 10 at
one time and then
you know like an hour later she gives
five more and would take them and then
it just you know i'd stay so [ __ ] up i
had my husband and he was not about time
of course he i was just 14 but 13 and 14
and
his brother would give me his whole
script of xanax's
i would take all them you know i
anything to not feel anything to not be
in reality
i hated it i hated my life i hated
everything
um
i was i was a huge [ __ ] i was not a
prostitute i was a [ __ ] [ __ ] when i
was a teenager i
i slept with all kinds of guys just
because
i thought that it would make them like
me i wanted people to like me
i wanted to love if it's what i wanted
and i never i still to this day haven't
felt
what i've wanted to feel you know what i
think love should be
um
not from no one except my kids maybe but
even that was taken away you know my
daughter you know don't want nothing to
do with me and that's
well i'm supposed to be unconditional
um would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in all of this
most important
have you learned anything honestly to
not trust anyone
you can't trust no one
um
and
drugs will absolutely ruin your life
ruin everything
but they get a hold of you and it's it's
it's the hardest thing i've ever done is
to try to get off of the moon really
i've um
had done everything you think of just to
get drugs you know
besides maybe kill someone
so the only thing i haven't done
all right well jessica thank you so much
for sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck in l.a thank
you be careful this neighborhood is
treacherous as well oh no
thank you it's just as bad as
appalachian
thank you thank you
you